hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the 2019 Greinke
chest classic it's again from round two
a spanish grandmaster Francisco Vallejo
pons also known as Paco faces a world
champion magnus cross and it's really an
interesting him but before you check it
out if you're interested you can check
out the impressions from round two
excellent quality video footage from the
grainy chess classic video team it will
be the first thing you will see in the
description below and also our
subscriber was passing by he visited the
grantee chess tournament and he sent me
two photos so we will show them here we
have this one that seems like it's still
the beginning of the game and also a
similar one there we have this one and I
will also put a link to his Instagram
page in page in the description below if
you're interested in some other photos
his name is mr. Pascal Croft and we do
have some video footage from this game
but we will save that for later as it is
well from the end game so without
further ado let's check it out
Paco has the white pieces and he opens
with efore with e5 Knight to f3 Knight
to c6 and here Bishop to b5 the reuleaux
pieces on the board and it's very
interesting I'm sure that everyone knows
that by now that if you play a 4 against
calls and he will go for his speche Nico
he played it in the World Championship
match against Fabiana Caruana then he
hope wants some very nice games in the
Mishima Memorial and here after Paco
played efore and Carson replied would be
5 I kind of think it was a it was a
pretty big surprise but as you'll see in
the game Park was - manages to surprise
Carlsen we have a 6 more fees defense
will give Bishop to a 4 and now Knight
to f6
we have castles by Paco and now comes
Bishop to c5
dr congo very a variation somewhat rarer
we have c3 call sand castles and now d4
Bishop to e7 and here we enter the line
that cross and played against Kerrigan
in the 2018 outer-box Norway
championship we have d captures on e5
Knight captures on e4 and here caller
kirkin continued with the Queen to d5 at
that game ended in a draw but here Paco
goes for a different line he goes for
the for the early Bishop to see
- it's a new move and as of this moment
from move nine we have a new game on our
hands and since the d5 square is no
longer occupied by the Queen
like cardigan plate here Carlsen just
plays d5 protects the knight on e4 and
offers if Paco
will capture it on poisson he does with
he captures and Aoife on d6 Knight
captures on d6 and now Bishop to g5 and
here I caught a glimpse of the live
coverage patrol echo was saying that it
will be very hard for Carlsen to look
for any advantage in this line with the
black pieces White's bishops are just
very nice and black I didn't really
create any disorder in the opening but
it doesn't seem that Carson is looking
for any opening advantage he just wants
to play a nice game she wants to have a
heaven equal position and then he wants
to play it for seven hours and if you
can get a draw with that then then you
have earned your draw or a win if you
can win but here cross and goes for f6
it is one of the positions where it is
okay to play f6 Bishop to f4 and now we
have g5 asking do you want to go back
Bishop to g3
or do you want to capture on d6 and
double up core since not double but mess
up cross since pawn structure and create
an isolated pawn on d6 and here Paco
decides to go for Bishop captures on d6
we have not pawn captures but Queen
captures on d6 Queen captures and now C
captures and here we have the same game
where the material on the board is
completely equal the differences cross
and has a weak pawn on d6 but he does
have the bishop repair so it's up to him
to use it last game we've seen cross and
used the knight pair now we'll see him
use the bishop pair
Knight bTW - white still has the finish
development we have G for Knights to h4
taking control of DF v square and now
comes d5 cross and wants to push d4 and
get rid of his weak D pawn with Knight
to f5 and now cousin does push d4 as it
is protected by the bishop and by the
night we have nice to see four by Paco
and now Bishop captures an f5 cost and
now gives up the light square Bishop
Bishop captures on f5 and now h5
defending the G for pawn with rook a to
D 1 and now rook F to D is just the
countering white rook on the D file and
a 4 by white and here Knight to e7
attacking the bishop here Bishop to e6
check with King to g7 and now rook after
a 1 which rook after he won
Paco pretty much finishes up his
development Carson has yet to do so as
he still has an undeveloped rockin a8
with f5 by Carson and now Knight to a5
going after the b7 pawn Carson has to
defend it we have rook a to b 8 and now
kink to f1 just improving the position
of the King you don't want to be stuck
on this diagonal at one point you might
want to play f3 and if this ever gets
captured it's gonna be a problem
King to have 6 improving the position of
the king and now Bishop the back to b3
preparing rook to e6 check which would
eventually win material so Knight to g6
getting the Knights to a safer Square
rook to e6 check with King to g5 and now
g3 and here as you can see cross and
skink isn't doing all that great here a
lot of squares are covered by the rook
and by the pawns here but he makes it
work with D captures in c3b captures on
c3 and now rook captures on d1 Bishop
captures on d1 and now rook to b8 going
after the bishop here but here Paco
finds an excellent resource he plays f4
and Carson says in an interview after
the game cross and said that he
underestimated this f4 move that it's a
very strong idea and that he definitely
considered playing something like Knight
captures here and just try and claim
that his two two extra points here are
enough compensation for a piece as the
knight on e5 isn't all that greatly
placed at least for the moment but he
decided to go for a different line after
I for he instead played the G captures
on f3 on pass on F capital captures on
f3 and now h4 and here is the moment
where Paco really had to figure out what
to do the best thing to do here is to go
for the pawn here Bishop captures on b7
you will eliminate this point you will
have a past eight point you will have a
past C pawn
well it's not all that simple as cross
and still has a very strong bishop he
can go rook to D to really take control
of the of the last rank
Paco's King will be stuck on f1 and if
the knight can also be activated there
are a lot of threats here you will have
to deal with some checks you're gonna
lose the H pawn and well Parker decided
not to go for this
so after h4 he went Knight to c4 he
didn't want to allow this rook to jump
all the way to d2 and allows Carlsen to
to equalize at least we have pawn
captures on g3 H captures and g3 and now
Bishop to b8 trying to grab the g3 pawn
as well we have King to g2 defending and
now b5 getting rid of the weaknesses on
the Queen side we have eight characters
on b5 a captures on b5 and now comes
Knight the e3 and here across and goes
for roof to d2 as the knight no longer
guards the d2 squared this comes with
check we have king to h3 and now rook to
d3 attacking well pressuring the knight
pressuring the bishop behind the night
but also going after the pawn and here
it's a it's a trade off upon for a pawn
so Parker goes Bishop to e2 going after
the b5 pawn rook captures Bishop
captures and now it's cousin who plays
f4 and it's a very nice idea because
yeah white cannot capture due to Knight
captures with check and you lose the
rook on e6
so after f4 with Bishop d8 hoping to
grab night only then capture the pawn
Knights the f8 my Carlsen pressuring the
rook we have looked a b6 going after the
bishop and now just the Bishop to e5 and
here if you play G captures on f4 which
you definitely want to do as you know
there's tension between pawns and if
it's not in your favor then you have to
get rid of it but here the problem is
the knight is pinned and now just King
captures and the King attacks the pinned
piece you're gonna lose a piece here so
after Bishop e5 we have Knights the f1
but this allows Crossin to grab the g3
pawn we have F captures and g3
now comes Luke the c6 and here a cross
and doesn't want to trade it seems like
you could trade and then claim that your
passport is winning but really it
not as it will be impossible to push it
over the the g2 that is a light square
after a few moves let's say 96 you will
go but up to e4 and after night to c7
let's say then you will just play Knight
captures on g3 and it's a it's a
perfectly drawn endgame
so after this rook the c6 we have looked
to a3 by Carson keeping the tension and
now comes Luke to b6 and here
rook to a2 hoping if the knight moves
then you can deliver rook to h2 which
would be a very nice checkmate but of
course that doesn't happen we have
looked a b4 and now Knight the e6
crossing has to figure out how to
activate the night as well rook to g4
this comes with check King back to f6
and now Bishop to c6 not allowing this
point to advance further from from from
g3 and also you are getting ready to
capture the pawn here on g3 so feel free
to pause the video here and try to
figure out what Carlson played in this
position how did he manage to gain
advantage from his passport I'll give
you a couple of seconds if you're
interested in perhaps doing it it's a
very nice idea for the Duke who were
able to do it congratulations you are an
excellent pusher of passed pawns and for
those who just want to enjoy show g2
just attacking the knight and the
problem is the knight has nowhere to go
you can go here you can go here you
block the roofs control of the G file
black and just Queen and if you go here
just row k3 then I just pinned and
you're gonna lose a piece so parco had
to capture the pawn we have Bishop
captures on g2 and now comes the cousins
idea nice to f4 check and now it's
impossible to get out of check any move
by the King oh it's a king here or King
here you will just capture with the
night because then it's a discovered
check from the butterfly taking h2 you
just capture it the knight is guarded by
the rook and it's checked from the
bishop so here you lose a piece so here
Paco had to give up the exchange we have
rook captures on f4
Bishop captures on f4 and now comes the
Bishop to f3 and here comes the position
where across and said in an interview
after the game it's move 51 and he
didn't know because there's this 50 move
rule of
and he thought he didn't know the does
he have 50 moves now trying to win this
game or does perhaps he have 75 moves
because there are some exceptions where
you have 75 moves instead of 50 50 moves
but later after the game young Gustavson
explained him explain to him that those
are the old rules that now you have 50
it's a 50 move rule for for everything
there there are no 75 move rules
I mean I don't know in draw that that's
what I've heard in the live coverage so
here cousin asked the arbiter and he
told him that he only has 50 moves but
he also said that okay he has he's on
the exchange he has a rook for a night
and we have the two bishops here but the
bishops are of opposite colors and
Carson said that he was sure if anything
that opposite color bishops are are
winning for the side that is up the
exchange so now that we've said that we
do have some footage here is a good
chance to check it out so let's check it
out here we have some nice footage from
the game it's not this exact position
but a few moves later but here just to
get in the mood for this final endgame
there haven't crossed makes a nice move
and also we have this one here also a
very nice close-up of Carlsen let's just
check it out there we have it there you
can see a blurry photo of Svidler in the
back not sure who's the one on the left
well yeah there we have it a very very
nice footage so I I do hope you enjoyed
that but now let's see how Carlson takes
care of this as he only has 50 moves so
first he goes back Bishop to b8 we have
nice - g3 and now Kings to g5 you have
to limit the movement of the White King
and hopefully deliver checkmate and it's
not all that easy to do it as you have a
dark square Bishop so you're not going
to be doing it in this corner as this is
a light square corner so you will most
likely have to pull the King over to the
dark square corner knights the e2 and
now comes Bishop to c7 King to g2 and
now
kink the h4 again taking the squares
away from the white king came to f2 and
now comes Bishop to b6 check King to e1
and now Bishop to e3
again taking squares away from the white
king preparing rook to e1 check which
would well force whites to lose material
so Kings to be one you want to create
some squares for your King to go to move
to and now kink the g5 you want to get
your king over to the center so you can
control the white king with your king as
well
Bishop to e4 you have king to f6 Bishop
to f3 and now King to e5 white just has
to make a few moves with the shop to g2
King to d6 Bishop to e4 and now kink the
c5 bush of the f5 and now comes looked
d2 with check and of course you cannot
go look to see one our King to see one
because you are going to under the mask
of the bishop so all sorts of nasty
discoveries will become possible so you
have to move King to e1 and now comes
look to d8 forcing white to make a move
and here white has to decide what to do
here white played Bishop to c4 but it's
not all that clear what to play play
something like King f1 then rook to f8
will we knew the game you just pin the
pin the bishop and after you defendant
just Bishop f4 attack the defender of
the pinned piece so after this rook
today by Carlson but shot to e4 was
played and now comes King to c4 we have
King to f1 and here once again feel free
to pause the video and try to find the
move Carlsen played as it is a very nice
idea I'll give you a couple of seconds
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
winner of game and games with opposite
colored bishops where you were up the
exchange and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show rook to f8 check
and now again if you go something like
King G 2 then rook F to check wins the
night here so that's not an option you
have to go back King to e1 and now comes
Bishop 2f to check after the game in an
interview of course and said that at
this moment where he delivered the
bishop to have to check he knew that he
was
winning but it's still it's still a very
interesting line kink the d2 now comes
Luke the d8 check you can see that the
bishop is controlling II won and III
King to c2 and now comes Bishop to e3
threatening rook to d2 check - once
again window night and here's the
problem what do you play here
Bishop to f3 was played in the game to
defend the night but the problem is if
you play something like 93 then we get a
similar line that happened in the game
Rudy to check King has to move and now
King b3 just threatening Ruby d1
checkmate and after Bishop to f3
controlling the d1 square root B to
check you have to go all the way into
the corner and now but should be for all
sorts of discoveries are now possible it
will be a very quick victory and
checkmate will follow so after Bishop to
e3 we have Bishop to f3 now defending
the knight but here comes rook the d2
check and now we entered the similar
line King b1 now comes King to b3 and
now Knight the c1 check King to a3 still
controlling all of the squares in front
of the White King Knight back to E - and
now rugby to check the bishop controls
the C 1 square so you have to go all the
way to the corner King to a 1 and now
rook to b8 but it doesn't really matter
you can move your look to any square
hopefully a dark square and it will be
just as nice so rook to b8
and it was in this position that
francisco bayeu hop-ons resigned the
game and yet another victory for magnus
carlsen who is now - in - in this
tournament after his victory over young
Vincent Kaymer what if you resign well
you have to make a move Bishop to d4
after the knight move if the knight
moves Bishop to d4 is the threat of
checkmate like 93 but d 4 will be
checkmate but if you don't if you keep
on guarding the d4 square doesn't really
matter you can just play any move with
the bishop let's say and then just
Bishop g5 and then you will go for this
checkmate or if white finds a way to to
take any other Square from the from the
bishop you can just go anywhere along
this diagonal and deliver checkmate this
way so doesn't really matter you can you
don't have to go here you can go push up
h6
it will still be the same line what a
white can stall a bit
it doesn't really make sense to do this
just captures and it's again checkmate
chef after this rook to b8 Paco resigned
and yet another victory for Magnus
Carlsen with the black pieces he started
with two black pieces this tournament
and well both of them ended and went for
him so definitely an impressive feat
like I said he's doing - very impressive
and we'll see we'll see where he takes
it from there yeah
once again do check out the link in the
description below it's the impressions
from round 2 excellent video footage but
a cranky chess classic video team do
check it out you know leave a comment
and you know say hi as there they're
really doing a wonderful job chef
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank universe Dixit
Chris Picard Bradley BD Joshua prim and
Kim Utterson for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the Grunk HS classic saga we
could say checking up on your
suggestions and if I will find time
continuing the couple Blancas saga in
between games I think you'll have an
excellent rest of your Sunday and I will
see you soon